amateur vs. professional in the hey guys
my name is day I work at BuzzFeed my
cooking list is a little short I'd know
how to make mac and cheese chocolate
chip cookies like when it comes with the
dough ready already I have a slight
cooking background I actually used to
work at Chipotle my whole college career
making burritos making quesadillas
making salads man oh let's kill in the
game I'm Alvin I'm a tasty Bruce it here
in BuzzFeed New York I've been cooking
for a while I love food and I love
cooking I believe that food is super
beautiful it really focused on making
food that I think is presentable as well
as delicious I feel super confident
going to gets Alvin you know this guy
might be the tasty King but I like the
lemonade King you give me anything and I
can make lemonade all I'm saying is
maybe the best cook win we're gonna find
out
[Music]
everyone's bridge is very different when
I go to my cousin's bridge what they
have their first completely different
than what I have in my fridge 30 minutes
is not a lot of time to make a meal
especially because you're a new kitchen
you're not sure what you're working with
but I think I can make it work you rate
this yeah let's do it
I'll do it all right it's on we're
coming for your ass
we're on our way to to Tara's house
maybe she's out of the fridge I have no
idea I feel like Tara lives right on
34th Street so like she's around so many
restaurants what would you have in your
fridge let's go see this house it's
empty with how's it gone
we try to year we're here for the 4 this
is amateur well it doesn't matter come
in hungry you better be don't you I just
woke up I got 5 minutes to check out
what food we got lying around what kind
of equipment we're dealing with the
special ingredient that I brought smoked
paprika I brought it because I think it
has a really nice flavor to a lot of
foods that could really take things to
the next level so open the fridge and
not knowing what to expect
I see eggs I see cheese I see maple
syrup I see bacon there's got some
leftovers here this is broccoli I could
totally use broccoli that's like a
breakfast thing broccoli goes with eggs
things are starting to work it's easy to
sort of follow a dish when you know what
angle you're going for so I think I got
something going on some sort of omelet
over maybe some bacon stuff with some
cheese sounds pretty good to me because
I am the master of all things wrapped in
tortillas it's only right that my
special ingredient was tortillas man I'm
just gonna take whatever is in this
fridge and put it in this wrap and make
it taste good let's check out what's in
this fridge she has onions cilantro she
has the lemon juice and the salt those
are really the only three ingredients I
use a lot
most of my foods oh we got avocados
girl all I need is avocados let me get
this guacamole up there
I got pico de gallo and guacamole I can
make a vegetarian burrito I really want
to make one with meat and I was going
through the fridge there weren't too
many leftovers but there was this little
Tupperware of Chinese food it looks like
some rice for some carrots with a little
bit of chicken we see if this smells
like it'll have to work guys I know
burritos he knows tasty let's see what
that looks like verses each other what
we're going alright here it is I don't
know if all my cooking techniques
alright so they're gone down Jade he's
going downtown after I whup your ass
oh you cutting the red onions too that's
gonna make you cry someone cue the
waterworks oh no like red onions are the
most acidic all that onion gas is like
going in the air and making her cry and
I felt so bad I started cutting those
red onions the teacher started falling
man I could not make them stop it was
really really bad it's gonna be such a
beautiful victory you know a bit if you
dance while you're doing it
I guess we're into it I don't know if it
helps every the eggs I personally
believe it does but that might just be
me talking it's the part where the syrup
goes in and it gets all glazed look at
what he's doing okay I'm gonna get this
nice and sticky hey it's hot though be
careful oh come on it's gonna be a bed
for the omelet oh I now got to use my
secret ingredient this little paprika
this avocado is really hard so I have to
slice it and dice it before I mash it so
that I'm not sitting here all day
mashing this
Krusty's simultaneously little lemon
juice I put jalapenos in my pico de
gallo and welcome on but because we
don't have hot opinions I saw some
jalapeno Pringles I think so I'm gonna
mash these down hope it turns into sauce
[Music]
and now I gotta had the leftovers so
it's this broccoli cheddar mix and I
kind of like put on the side of the
omelet
I think the moment I rolled my omelet I
kind of knew I'd take it at home he
really thinks he's gonna win his
confidence is here and I'm gonna need
him to come here
this guy's thinks that this is a tasty
video that's my boy right there
whoa the hell was that Elvis almonds
over here with chips and he's making
some kind of chip concoction and he's
calling it and garnish there we have it
why make an even playing field and let
me make a breakfast burrito as well so
instead of using the leftover rice and
chicken as like a dinner kind of style
burrito I'll take the chicken out of the
rice and then put that in some eggs make
a little omelet put the omelet in the
burrito with some pico de gallo
guacamole success on the platter [ __ ]
are you trying to copy me that's what I
do when I cook I just throw [ __ ]
together whatever in front of me that's
what's going in we're just gonna cook
some bacon as a snack go ahead and throw
these eggs in there I like my eggs
cheesy doing
I ain't copy you Alvin get the hell out
of here you're using Kraft singles -
what that's the only cheesy exercise I
know for a fact it wasn't me that set
off the fire alarm I'm 100% sure Jay set
the fire alarm off there's no way I
could do it now back to what I was doing
then I lay that guacamole on the bottom
you know pico de gallo next you know
what my Chipotle experienced my rollin
skills are impeccable so that burrito
looked immaculate after I rolled it
[Music]
I've been sitting in my room for what
feels like forever because I've been
smelling all kinds of different smells
some good some intense some fire alarms
but we have two beautifully presented
dishes and I'm gonna start with this one
I can see there's some Doritos on top
got some bacon on the bottom oh oh look
at that cheese ball that is so good
number two it's like some toppings but
it's a burrito so I'm just gonna kind of
like saucer it
I was oh really then there's a lot of
different flavors it looks like we have
some of my leftover chicken which has
been in there for not really sure how
long but I love the creativity in that
there's some eggs or some pico de gallo
there's there's a lot though both dishes
were really so good but now I have to
choose a winner so let's bring in the
chef's it was a really hard decision and
you guys are both my really good friends
I'm gonna have to go with the bacon and
egg on way the bacon cheese pull keep
saying I'm gonna have to award you okay
no I wasn't finished foot in that you
know that bacon does legit you should
try it
[Music]
[Music]